Sam kiley, CNN, eastern
Ukraine.
>> Wow, what incredible
reporting there from Sam kiley
and his team.
I want to bring in CNN military
analyst and retired air force
colonel Cedric Leighton.
Colonel, thank you so much for
joining us at this hour.
What would western supply
planes mean to Ukraine and its
ability to push Russia back?
>> Well, between planes and
helicopters, you would have a
quite good mix for the
Ukrainians to actually go after
the Russians.
Not only on the front lines but
behind the front lines.
So this, is, yeah I think one
of the key factors the
Ukrainians are still looking
for.
One of the key factors that is
also missing from any type of
modern military operation.
Either side has been able to
declare air supremacy over the
Ukraine or even air superiority
over Ukraine.
And if the uk idiots were able
to get air support, he even
into the localized areas, that
would be a huge deal for them.
, Now one of the big questions,
of course, is how well and how
quickly can they be trained to
use different equipment?
You know, what Sam shared with
the M.I.A. Helicopters.
That is about a two generation
ago in terms of helicopters and
aviation.
If they're going to be brought
up to speed that is going to be
a different situation.
And it certainly takes some
time to do.
That >> Yeah, there is a lot of
technology that has been
majorly updated and a lot of
things to learn.
Next week, and I cannot believe
this.
But it marks the one year
anniversary of Russia's
invasion in Ukraine.
I remember at the time when it
first happened that the U.S.
Intelligence at the time had
said that probably Russia was
going to take the capital Kyiv
in three days.
That could not have, and of
course and there have been
re-thinks of all of, this is
actually on Russia's side.
Did you think the war would be
where it is today?
Not knowing what you know now?
>> Yeah, hindsight is of course
always 2020, right, Sarah?
But I think the big takeaway
here is that the Ukrainians
confounded most expectations
they were on the Russian side
or the Ukrainian side.
Even certainly on the western
side.
I think a lot of people
expected a repeat of 1968 when
the soviet union and the Warsaw
pact invaded what was then
czechoslovakia to get rid of
that relatively thorough
communist reform at that point.
But, you, know Ukraine is quite
different.
And Ukraine had tasted freedom.
They knew that they had to
fight in order to survive.
And that's very fact, I think
it surprised many of us.
And I think that is the key
thing.
It is quite a surprisingly
thing that they do this.
Now that we are at this point,
they need, the Ukrainians need
a lot more jobs of ammunition
and the ability to actually
regain the territory they've
lost.
They've done a major job in
recapture in a lot of territory
up to this point.
But they haven't quite gotten
what they want in order to
achieve that stalemate that
they are looking for.
>> Yeah there is still some
horrible bloody battles.
They continue and continue to
take civilians lives.
One of the things about being
on the ground there from my
perspective is there were a few
things that really changed the
tenor and tone of this.
One of them was zelenskyy.
Him staying in place.
Him fighting back himself.
And not just putting his
countryman in front, on the
front line.
The other is that the Ukrainian
people aren't having.
It, like you talk about his
grandmother's, to grandbabies?
.
--
the U.S. Has been warning its
allies that China may increase
its military support of
Ukraine.
And what that would mean.
I would like to hear from you
what do you think that would
mean, if China decides to start
supplying Russia with whatever
it may need.
Although everyone thought that
Russia's forces were stronger
than Ukraine's.
But what would that mean going
forward for Ukraine?
>> Yeah, certainly we would
have some problems for Ukraine.
I think one of the key things
to think about here is the huge
disparity in terms of numbers
between the Ukrainians and the
Russians.
The Russians about --
ten times the defense budget of
the Ukrainians.
And, that you, know was also
reflected in personnel numbers.
But what we have learned since
then is that the quantitative
ability of the Russians and the
quantitative ponderance of the
Russians is really not a match
for the Ukrainians as long as
the Ukrainians get the weapons
that they need from the west.
So the Chinese, if they support
the Russians, you know, in a
major way, that is going to put
a strain on the Ukraine.
It's also going to put a strain
on, nato nato will have to step
up its game, the defense
industrial base is going to
have to play a huge part in
resupplying Ukrainians, and it
is going to have to do so,
they're very quickly.
We have to expect the Chinese
to do this.
But we have to act accordingly.
>> Okay, this is an unprovoked
war from the auspices of
Ukraine side.
Russia invaded for no apparent
reason other than wanting to
take a territory.
So we will see what happens in
the end.
But I know that the Ukrainians